wählt auf keinen fall die cdu und die
spd
millionenfach wurde dieser aufruf auf
youtube angeklickt und tatsächlich junge
leute haben die parteien der gruppe bei
der europa wahl abgestraft meinungsmache
schimpft die cdu-vorsitzende und fordert
regeln für die debatte im netz
die große koalition leidet sie sucht
nach antworten und trifft aber doch
irgendwie nicht den richtigen ton streit
um meinungsfreiheit youtuber gegen groko
unser thema heute in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin wo immer sie uns
zuschauern im fernsehen oder im internet
meine gäste sind ruprecht polenz von der
cdu bis 2013 saß er im bundestag zuletzt
war er vorsitzender des auswärtigen
ausschusses war auch mal generalsekretär
der cdu und ist sehr aktiv bei facebook
und bei twitter
karin moor begrüße ich herzlich sie ist
die leiterin des newsrooms der spd das
ist etwas neues zuvor war sie bei
spiegel online tätig und weil der bild
zeitung auch davor war sich für social
media verantwortlich hut zu bekommen
robin blase ist bei uns seit über zehn
jahren betreibt er ob babbel das ist ein
youtube kanal zu aktuellen internet
themen und zur politik mit der
bundeszentrale für politische bildung
hat er videos zur europawahl produziert
und hat auch zum beispiel über die
münchner sicherheitskonferenz berichtet
und markus decker ist bei uns er
berichtet seit 2001 aus der hauptstadt
also kennen sich gut aus dem politischen
betrieb jetzt ist der
parlamentskorrespondenz für das
redaktions netzwerk rnd die beliefern
mehrere regionalzeitungen
herr polenz nicht quasi von vorne
anfangen und dann gucke ich sie hin aber
froh ich wollte mit ihnen anfangen ein
video 12 millionen klicks inzwischen vor
der wahl was sagst du 34 millionen und
die ganze republik spricht darüber wieso
hat das geschafft was die spd nicht
schafft warum schafft die spd so was
nicht
naja lars klingbeil hat anfang der woche
auf diese frage bei hart aber fair
gesagt leicht sollten wir mehr über
inhalte sprechen weniger über
personaldebatten und natürlich schließt
sich daran auch an die frage wo müssen
wir eigentlich sein also wo müssen wir
mit menschen reden und diese frage
stellen sich natürlich gerade auch alle
ich glaube in aigen parteizentralen
aber ein platz wäre ja dann das netz das
internet also miteinander zu reden
klartext die spd ja auch also timo
wirken ist ja unser vorzeige youtuber
wenn man so will das war ja auch einer
der ersten wer geantwortet hat auf
dieses risiko video mit einem youtube
statement das ja auch in dieser
community erstmal gut aufgenommen wurde
und davon brauchen wir natürlich viel
viel mehr
dafür sind sie dann zuständig reden wir
gleich mal darüber wie das funktioniert
herr polenz was kann rieso also dieser
youtuber macht die cdu nicht kann dinge
auf den punkt gebracht er hat eine
sprache gefunden die offensichtlich
nerven getroffen hat also gar
viele und er hat damit geschafft dass es
eine wechselwirkung gab zwischen der
reaktion im netz und daneben auch den
klassischen medien das hat sich
gegenseitig befeuert und dadurch hat es
zwischen glaube ich über zwölf millionen
wii hus gegeben die haben es nicht alle
zu ende gesehen aber das ist schon eine
gewaltige zahl
wenn sie sagen hat den nerv getroffen
heißt dass die cdu weiß nicht mehr genau
was jetzt gerade spielt gerade bei
jungen leuten doch aber als partei kann
man natürlich dinge nicht in der
gleichen weise vortragen das wäre auch
der falsche ehrgeiz aber die cdu hatte
sicherlich auch nach den
meinungsumfragen was ist der menschen
wichtig in dieser wahl nicht die
richtigen themen die menschen wollten
über klimaschutz reden und das thema war
durch freies for future und die
wissenschaft und viele artikel war topp
und darüber hätten die menschen
wahrscheinlich auch gerne mit der cdu
gesprochen aber es war nicht bei uns und
ob in der agenda der blase wie erklären
sie sich dass das sieben menschen sich
auf einmal jungen menschen die so für
politik interessieren wir immer gesagt
haben die interessieren sich eigentlich
für politik sie sind ja schon lange
unterwegs in dem ganzen feld haben wir
das falsch eingeschätzt haben wir gesagt
das stimmt gar nicht weil eigentlich
gibt schon immer ein großes politik
interesse bei jugendlichen
ich glaube es ist eine mischung also ich
da auf der einen seite haben sich junge
menschen schon immer für themen
interessiert und vielleicht weniger für
parteien oder persönlichkeiten in der
politik und jetzt gerade ging es halt
gerade in letzter zeit im internet um
themen für future ist im umweltschutz
artikel 13 es geht um urheberrecht das
waren zwei themen die sehr stark besetzt
wurden von jungen menschen sehr stark
besetzt nun im internet und dann auch
sehr stark besetzt wurden auf der straße
in demos und ja beides themen die aber
gefühl nicht ernst genommen wurden von
der politik und wo glaube ich jetzt
unter anderem deswegen ein großes
interesse kam dann doch sich mehr damit
auseinanderzusetzen ist da dieses thema
urheberrecht war ja wirklich groß wie
carmen dass das nicht ernst genommen
wurden
und hat das viele politisiert wie das
kam weiß ich nicht ich hätte mir da auf
jeden fall mehr reaktionen auf augenhöhe
gewünscht aber ich glaube dass das mit
reingespielt hat ja also ich glaube was
bisher wenig diskutiert wurde ist dass
diese zwölf millionen natürlich jetzt
inzwischen auch viel drauf geklickt
haben wegen medienberichten aber am
anfang haben wie sauce abonnenten die
sonst ganz andere videos auf seinem
kanal gewöhnt sind da drauf geklickt und
es wurde viel darüber diskutiert ob
widersteht zerstörung im titel deswegen
haben sie darauf gelegt das ist ja was
ganz großes
sie haben darauf liegt auf dem video in
dem cdu im titel steht das muss man
erstmal schaffen junge menschen dazu zu
bringen auf ein video zu drücken den cdu
darin steht egal zerstörung hin oder her
es ist von anfang an jedem zuschauer
bevor er drauf blick sichtbar
das geht um politik und es geht 55
minuten um politik und ich glaube von
paar jahren hat ein junger menschen da
nicht drauf geklickt also muss dieses
interesse irgendwo her gekommen sein und
auch das interesse an einer zerstörung
der cdu irgendwo her gekommen sein
und ich glaube da hat artikel 13
sicherlich mit reingespielt sind ja eher
ein hartes wort zerstörung der cdu
herdecker finden sie die fanden sie das
richtig dass dass es so klar also dass
auch so benannt wurde also und das will
und wie fanden sie dann auch die
reaktion der cdu darum ja ich finde das
video insgesamt ein bisschen polemisch
bisschen sehr polemisch ich finde vieles
was da gesagt wird richtig in der sache
richtig aber das problem finde ich dass
vieles nicht benannt wird
auch was das für probleme gibt zb bei
der frage wie schützen wir eigentlich
das klima wieso redet zb über über den
ausstieg aus der braunkohle
was er nicht so benennt und nicht
thematisiert ist dass das eben auch jobs
kostet und dass das zum beispiel jobs
kostet in gegenden wo es heute schon
wenig jobs gibt in brandenburg zum
beispiel oder in sachsen wo jetzt gerade
landtagswahl statt gefunden haben wo die
afd jeweils stärkste partei geworden ist
und wo es schwierig ist einfach jetzt
noch mal ein strukturwandel
herbeizuführen
die frage wie die cdu reagiert hat da
kann ich nur sagen das ist eine glatte 6
sie hat erst mal ein video angekündigt
und das video dann nicht veröffentlicht
also das video von philippe am tor
sie hat sich dann nicht entscheiden
können ob sie sozusagen draufhaut auf
wieso oder ob sie ein gesprächsangebot
gemacht erst hat sie das eine getan und
dann hat sich das andere getan und das
frau kramp karrenbauer jetzt die frage
aufgeworfen hat ob man denn da
irgendetwas regulieren könne oder müsse
das ist natürlich fatal und die reaktion
darauf die reaktionen zeigen auch dass
daß der schuß jetzt voll nach hinten los
gegangen ist aber auch andere reaktion
von der cdu r
herr polenz sie haben auf facebook einen
brief geschrieben an riesen den
veröffentlichen haben sie auch
geschrieben zuerst hat mich dein video
zerstört die cdu wahnsinnig geärgert
haben sie inzwischen und dann haben sie
ganz ausgeführt sehr ausführlich
geschrieben warum haben sie diesen brief
geschrieben und haben sie eine antwort
erhalten
also ich habe den brief geschrieben weil
ich schon darauf reagieren wollte und
weil ich das war jetzt glaube ich der
dritte oder vierte tag nach der
veröffentlichung des videos von meiner
partei bis dahin nichts gesehen hatte
und dachte man muss ja da auch irgendwie
drauf reagieren und ich wollte deutlich
machen einmal und ich muss anders
ausdrücken ich hatte am anfang 23 teams
dazu gemacht und darauf ein bisschen
zustimmung auch viel kritik bekommen
weil ich so aus dieser ärger haltung
geschrieben hatte man habe ich mir das
nochmal in ruhe überlegt und dann
versucht die punkte anzusprechen wo ich
sage also da hat er recht und habe das
auch gesagt aber ich habe eben zb eben
in seinen außenpolitischen passagen
widersprochen ich fand er hat zu wenig
über terrorismus und nichts über es
gesagt sondern sich nur an den drohnen
der amerikaner abgearbeitet
und ich habe immer auch recht gegeben
was den umgang meiner partei
weitestgehend jedenfalls in den lauten
stellungnahme gegenüber fall ist future
anging ich sagte dass deshalb laute
stellungen haben als zum beispiel unser
oberbürgermeister wenn man es ja der ist
zu denen hin hat mit denen diskutiert
und da ist ein ganz anderes gespräch
auch in die gänge gekommen
es war nicht überall so aber die lauten
stellungnahmen sind immer wenn eine
politische forderung aufgestellt wird
klimaschutz und dann ist die antwort aus
meiner partei die die vielleicht der
schulleiter gibt wie macht ihr das dann
am freitag mit dem unterricht statt auf
das politische thema zu antworten ich da
ist doch was nicht in ordnung
also es gibt ja anscheinend dann eine
sehnsucht nach einer inhaltlichen
auseinandersetzung
warum nehmen die parteien das nicht an
herr blase das weiß ich nicht
da müsste nicht rechtlich aber wäre
stehe ist ehrlich gesagt also ich würde
mir genau das wünschen also beiträge 13
haben wir das gesehen genauso perfekt
wie fischer genau so wie jetzt bei
diesem video also da sind junge menschen
die hier eigentlich genau das machen was
seit jahren oder jahrzehnten oder
generationen gefordert wird junge
menschen sollten sich bitte mehr für
politik begeistern
damit haben ganz viele politiker hatten
keine ahnung davon kann das sein auf
jeden fall ich hat sich anscheinend noch
ganz viele politiker keine ahnung von
klimaschutz
[Musik]
wenn es um die wenn das eine sehnsucht
gibt noch eine etage italienischen nach
einer inhaltlichen auseinandersetzung
warum oder wie können sie darauf
reagieren was überlegen sie da jetzt in
der spd was überlegen sie im willy
brandt haus seit das jetzt so ein
wichtiges thema ist wie sie damit
umgehen sollen
das hat ja verschiedene ebenen also eine
inhaltliche ebene eine kommunikative
ebene und vor allem glaube ich gibt es
da eben ganz viele fragen weil es gibt
jetzt nicht in einen hebel den mann
ziehen kann damit das alles funktioniert
und
wir müssen antworten geben die spd muss
jetzt doch eine antwort geben was
überlegen sie da also lars klingbeil hat
ja auf der inhaltlichen ebene erst mal
schon ganz offen und klar gesagt ja wir
waren beim thema klimaschutz nicht
präsent genug auf den platz wir haben da
nicht genug gemacht und das wollen wir
aber jetzt wir sind da dran und wir
wollen auch die die bremse wie er immer
sagt dazu kriegen das klimaschutzgesetz
jetzt auch wirklich durchzusetzen so das
ist die inhaltliche ebene bei der
kommunikativen ebene ja klar geht es
jetzt darum sich noch mal zu fragen was
sind eigentlich die kanäle auf denen wir
sein müssen wie schaffen wir es formate
zu schaffen schneller zu reagieren
schneller vom hof zu kommen wenn es
darum geht solche gesprächsangebote auch
anzunehmen und ich bin halt total gute
dinge dass uns das gelingen wird aber
hat denn jetzt solche wieso ihr
gesprächsangebot angenommen und hatte
auf ihren brief reagiert ja er hat kurz
vor der sendung noch getwittert
tatsächlich und hat auch noch mal gesagt
so haben unterschiedliche parteien
reagiert und hatte auch geschrieben ja
ich habe gesprächsangebote bekommen und
nehmen die auch total gerne an und das
geht ja nicht darum dass direkt ins
scheinwerferlicht zu stellen und damit
damit wieder pr zu machen sondern es
geht ja tatsächlich ums reden und zu
sagen wir sind da wir hören zu und wir
machen das nicht nur aus aus show
sondern weil wir wirklich damit was
machen wollen aber decker machen sich
youtuber vielleicht manchmal auch zu
einfach weil eben politischer prozesse
kompliziert sind weil sie verschiedene
interessen immer mehr berücksichtigen
müssen sie es gibt ja auch den vorwurf
dass es eigentlich auch eine art des
populismus ist wie würden sie sagen
sollte
ja die vorwurf dass das populismus sei
den habe ich selber erhoben in einem
kommentar ich würde auch dabei bleiben
also populistisch findig wenn der
eindruck erweckt wird manche dinge seien
einfach ganz einfach so also den den
klimawandel zu bekämpfen das sei einfach
ganz einfach das gegenteil ist ja der
fall wenn man entschlossen klimaschutz
politik betreiben will dann muss man
ganz tief sozusagen in strukturen dieser
gesellschaft und dieser wirtschaft
eingreifen also über den
braunkohletagebau da habe ich eben schon
ein paar worte gesagt die
automobilindustrie davon hängen
eine million und mehr arbeitsplätze ab
die kann man nicht einfach umstellen mit
einem fingerschnipsen auf e-mobilität
das thema fliegen ist ein thema was alle
menschen betrifft auch viele junge
menschen dann ist eben schluss mit dem
wochenend trip nach barcelona oder mit
dem mit dem konzert in london sondern ja
dann muss man sich was einfallen lassen
da muss man mit dem zug fahren oder
darauf so auch zum wochenendtrip eben
komplett verzichten man muss dann auch
mehr geld in die hand nehmen um so etwas
zu realisieren
und dass das all das nicht auftaucht
barroso das finde ich macht macht
sozusagen sollen populismus aus aber ich
glaube nicht dass wir so in irgendeiner
form gesagt was er möchte dass das mit
dem finger schnipsen passiert im
gegenteil er kritisierte die politik die
in der vergangenheit passiert ist und
hätte sich da einfach schon eine längere
vorbereitung gewünscht dass man eben mit
dem wir jetzt konfrontiert sind und ich
glaube die sichtweise ist er wird
sicherlich mit nicht mit dem finger
schon nichts passieren aber es müsste
eigentlich mit einem fingerschnipp
basieren und das traurige ist ja das ist
ebenso komplexes in das neue
herausforderung vor der wir stehen wenn
ich da ganz kurz widersprechen darf
wieso hat wörtlich gesagt cdu und spd
müssen nur das umsetzen was die
wissenschaftler sagen sie müssen nur das
umsetzen dass das ist okay so
besonders stark die passage wo noch mal
auf den punkt gebracht hat was
eigentlich klar ist wir verhandeln
normalerweise interessenausgleich und
suchen kompromisse
die natur macht aber keine und wir haben
neun jahre zeit
und diese botschaft ist unheimlich stark
rüber gekommen und sie ist richtig und
die müssen jetzt auch als eine chance
verstehen um diejenigen die entweder
sagen also klimawandels immer gegeben
oder klimawandel menschen haben keinen
einfluss wenn sie einfluss haben dann
kommt man nach china das ist ja diese
form der diskussion die wir dauernd
haben und da kann jetzt auch eine chance
erwachsen wenn wir wenn wir verstehen
wir haben future filings for future wir
haben riese wir haben viele andere die
uns helfen jetzt diejenigen zu
überzeugen den wir in der tat
veränderung im verhalten zumuten müssen
uns selber natürlich auch verstehe
eigentlich nicht warum wir so viel
darüber reden ob dieses video als
populistisch ist oder zugespitztes oder
irgendwas ich glaube dass es ein erster
stelle gar nicht die frage sondern da
ist gerade eine tür aufgegangen
er ist aufgegangen zu einer generation
zu einer bestimmten community und zu
einem bestimmten anliegen und erste
station zu sagen ja gut aber bei minute
da stimmte das vielleicht nicht ganz
genau und das ist zugespitzt
darum geht es doch erst mal überhaupt
nicht es geht doch erstmal darum durch
diese tür zu gehen und nicht wie die
union irgendwie fünf blöcke weiter zu
stehen und ihre straßenkarte nicht
aufgefallen zu kriegen aber wie will ok
dann machen jetzt konkret wie geht die
spd durch diese tür sie haben ein
gesprächsangebot gemacht und heißt das
sie würden sich jetzt auch sozusagen in
ihrem parteipolitischen entscheidungen
daran messen lassen oder wie
funktioniert das erst mal haben sie ein
schlechtes wahlergebnis gehabt und nur
sieben prozent der bevölkerung glauben
dass die spd den der zukunft für die
zukunft gestalten kann also die kriegen
ja erstmal ganz schlechte noten also was
wir ja bereits was die spd ja bereits
gemacht hat ist zwei mal öffentlich zu
antworten nämlich einmal mit timo welken
und einmal haben sich kevin kühnert
kinofilmen und lars klingbeil sofort vor
die kamera gesetzt zwischen
zisch terminen in einer gaming halle
weil das die einzige situation war wo es
ging also erst mal dieses schnelle
reagieren und zu sagen wir sind da ja
der dörfer 210.000 leute gesehen das ist
nichts gegen die klicks dieses sich
ursprungs video hat und das ist auch
ganz hat über die cdu nicht über die spd
ja also ich glaube zwar nur 10.000
menschen sind wahrscheinlich 209.000
mehr als das pdf von der union gelesen
haben
also ich würde gerne von dieser
kommunikationsweise spannend das ist wir
können noch lange drüber werden aber für
mich ist die klimafrage keine jugend
frage für mich sie ist auch keine frage
sozusagen einer bestimmten zielgruppe
sind es eigentlich unser aller thema und
die chance die man jetzt hat ist eben
das auch als aller thema somit
aufzugreifen das auch zu spüren
ja die nein es ist ja nicht richtig die
cdu hat das ja auch nicht in der
direkten reaktion hat
das war jetzt wieder das kommunikations
thema dazu vielleicht ganz kurz ich
hätte kein video versucht zu machen weil
risi hat ansagen video sicherlich wochen
gearbeitet und da kann man nicht als
partei so ein schnellschuss machen sie
etwas anderes wenn die an der bären ist
sie vor die kamera stellt und macht da
15 minuten was das ist authentischer
kann die partei nicht machen ich habe
ganz einfach gesagt ich habe das gesehen
lass uns drüber sprechen machen
terminvorschlag punkt fertig aus also
dass das man einfach dann auch wieder
sozusagen auf ein format kommt wo man
selber auch mithalten kann ich glaube
nicht dass irgendein video produzieren
ich hab nicht mehr doch ganz klar noch
mal also wir reden über zwei
verschiedene dinge die im grunde
vollkommen verschieden sind wir reden
einmal wo das thema in erster linie zur
das thema klimaschutz da teile ich
vollkommen die position dass wir da
keine zeit haben
ich bin ein fan von beatenberg die sich
immer nüchtern oder relativ nüchtern und
sachlich äußert die nicht politisiert
die allenfalls ihre ängste zum ausdruck
bringt und sagt diese angst ist auch
angebracht
also da da bin ich voll kabine
aber wir reden eben auch über formen von
politischer kommunikation und unser
thema in den letzten jahren seit beginn
der so genannten flüchtlingskrise war
mehr denn je das thema populismus war
war wie wir kommunizieren nicht zuletzt
im netz welche welcher härte von kritik
dann noch noch statthaft ist welche
welche form von kommunikation und
darüber müssen wir schon auch gegen ich
habe noch genau wie schaffen wir es denn
dann aber ob im netz oder woanders
die debatten zu führen die ja nun ganz
viele und nicht nur jugendliche für
wichtig halten babbel wollte ich schon
sagen lässt der internet name bleibe wie
schaffen wir das dass wir halt einfach
wieder in den inhaltlichen austausch
kommen wo wir uns nicht nur gegenseitig
jeweils in die eine oder andere ecke
stellen ich glaube die über inhalte
reden also nach dem wieso video hab ich
ganz viele sachen gesehen über er hat
blaue haare ihre kinder im internet
da habe ich jetzt heute morgen gesehen
ich glaube sprecher der cdu fraktion in
berlin
verschwörungstheorie gepostet dass man
ja mal angucken sollte wer hinter rieso
steckt mal im impressum steht ja ein
youtube management sowie bei allen
youtuber natürlich sind künstler bei
managements unter vertrag
also wenn das die reaktionen sind auf
inhaltliche kritik dann kann man sich ja
auch nicht drüber unterhalten und das
haben wir leider eben jetzt nicht nur
weil die video gesehen sondern auch bei
den themen die wir schon angesprochen
haben die davor
wie sind ihre erfahrungen da weil sie
waren jetzt eben mit europawahl vor der
europawahl unterwegs war noch in ganz
europa unterwegs ist ihre erfahrung wie
kriegt man wir also diese diskussionen
und debatten über die politische inhalte
ja weiter getragen dass sie eben auch
nicht nur für eine kleine blase da sind
ich glaube am ehesten indem man sich
nicht daran festmacht wie die cdu es zum
beispiel kurz versuchte zu sagen wir
müssen jetzt den jüngsten politiker
neben den wir finden können und setzen
den von der kamera und damit das ist
ganz cool hit das ist nicht der richtige
ansatz ich habe der richtige ansatz ist
leute zu finden die mit leidenschaft und
authentizität an das thema eingehen ich
finde wie sie das ja machen also ihr
brief ist genau die antwort die ich mir
ehrlich gesagt von allen cdu politikern
gewünscht hätte nämlich zu sagen es gibt
ein paar punkte die sehe ich anders aber
ich respektiere dich für deine punkte
und ich nehme auch ernst was du gesagt
hast und erstmal auch danke dafür dass
du überhaupt erziehung herzstich
politisch irgendwie engagiert das habe
ich gar nicht gehört von irgendjemand
anderem sonst und das finde ich sehr
schade ich glaube das ist ein total
wichtiger punkt oder das worüber wir
gerade sprachen
dieser vertrauensverlust den gibt es ja
nicht nur gegenüber der politik sondern
auch gegenüber der presse also menschen
misstrauen mehr als früher der presse
der politik und eine lösung dafür oder
ein ansatz den versuch könnte es sein zu
sagen vielleicht müssen wieder menschen
mit menschen reden weil ich glaube das
ist vielleicht eine ganz alte wahrheit
immer noch war als menschen vertrauen
menschen und das ist ja auch das was
wieso gemacht hat er hat ja erst mal mit
seiner community gesprochen oder das
heißt eigentlich müssen wir brauchen wir
mehr menschen wie sie ganz
offensichtlich auch keine frage der
generationen
wo man ist wo man mit menschen spricht
und ich würde mir wünschen dass es viel
mehr politikerin politiker geht er gibt
die die auch für sich herausfinden wo
bin ich gut das macht mir spaß schreibe
ich rede ich filme ich aber damit raus
zu gehen um einfach wieder direkt mit
menschen zu sprechen da will ich gerne
einen satz noch zu sagen wenn ich so mit
kollegen früher gesprochen habe macht
doch mal ein bisschen mehr geht
diskutiert auf facebook mit und haben
das habe ich nur facebook gemacht oder
auf twitter egal
dann läuft das seitdem unter der
überschrift in social media ag
das heißt ich gehe zu menschen das muss
man verstehen
also ich gehe nicht sozusagen zu einem
medium sondern ich gehe zu menschen die
ich über das medium erreiche und das ist
ja auch genau das wie es empfunden wird
wenn dort keine politiker sind oder wenn
sie sozusagen kommunikation
missverstehen als ich sende was und
kommunikation heißt aber auch zuhören
und antworten ja so und das ist das was
passieren muss und das kann auch keine
parteizentrale abnehmen das muss jeder
politiker heute machen der mandat hat
mindestens sie haben eben das wort
vertrauen gesagt und vertrauen in presse
auch im journalismus hat der gates haben
wir auf der anderen seite aber eine
entwicklung sie leiten ein newsroom bei
der spd
es gibt eine news schon bei der cdu es
gibt a f d tvs gibt cdu tv es gab die
aussage von frau kramp karrenbauer nach
einem werkstattgespräch wo sie
fernsehteams nicht zugelassen
wir wollen herr über die eigenen bilder
seien also das ist ja eine entwicklung
die hat ja nicht mit viel vertrauen in
die presse zu tun wie beurteilen sie als
journalist
ich möchte erstmal an der stelle sagen
dass sich die bewertung unserer arbeit
an dieser stelle auch ein bisschen
widersprüchlich finde
insofern als uns journalisten in den
letzten jahren vielfach gesagt worden
ist wir hätten das thema flüchtlinge
unterschätzt
wir hätten das nicht zum thema gemacht
zugespitzt in der formulierung wir seien
eigentlich alle
linksgrün versucht dass das war der
vorwurf der uns in den letzten jahren
gemacht worden ist und jetzt kommt der
vorwurf auf einmal aus einer ganz
anderen richtung jetzt wird uns gesagt
wir hätten das thema klimakrise nicht
thematisiert wir werden auf dem auge
irgendwie blind das finde ich beides
zusammen kann irgendwie nicht stimmen
er würde ich sagen dass beide urteile
bisschen oberflächlich sind und und der
realität einfach nicht standhalten
jetzt zu ihrer frage ich glaube einfach
dass durch die digitalisierung so ist
dass die klassischen medien nicht mehr
die sogenannte gatekeeper funktion haben
also wir sind nicht mehr diejenigen die
sozusagen alleine bestimmen was was was
zu sagen was ja aber was und vorüber und
zu welchem zeitpunkt informiert wird das
bringt einfach die digitalisierung mit
sich davon sind funk und fernsehen
genauso betroffen wie die zeitungen so
und im online ist es einfach so dass es
da mehr player gibt
das ist aber jetzt auch player gibt die
sich wo es heißt sie machen einen
newsroom aber news machen sie natürlich
nicht sondern sie machen parteipolitik
so also da findet kein journalismus
statt
und wieso und die youtuber also ich kann
jetzt nicht für alle youtuber sprechen
bleiben wir bei rhi sowas wieso macht
ist natürlich kein journalismus sondern
das ist ja auf diese bezeichnung danach
so funktionieren ja ja klar ist es ist
unterm strich so dass wir uns in einer
medialen revolution befinden
die wo es ein hohes maß an
beschleunigung gibt wo es mehr
interaktion gibt zwischen sender und
empfänger wo es neue player gibt und
wohl auch so zu sagen wo alle auch
lernen
sind und wo jetzt einfach da wird jetzt
einfach neues spiel angepfiffen neues
spiel ist müsste man da nicht auch neue
spielregeln haben froh wenn sie sagen
das was sie da willy brandt kam das ist
ein newsroom machen journalismus machen
die parteipolitik was machen sie da also
der begriff newsroom beschreibt ja
erstmal nur eine organisationsstruktur
in amerika wird er betrifft ganz häufig
verwendeten nicht journalistischen
kontext es geht erst mal nur darum nach
relevanz zu bewerten und zu entscheiden
in welcher form spielen wir sie auf
welchem kanal aus so und journalistische
newsroom funktioniert das natürlich nach
journalistischen kriterien unabhängig
frei und und meinungen werden als solche
gekennzeichnet in einem politischen
newsroom
ich hänge persönlich übrigens gar nicht
an dem begriff aber dazu gleich noch mal
in einem politischen newsroom natürlich
geht es immer um partei kommunikation
und natürlich wird da immer im sinne der
partei entschieden und ich glaube dann
aber wir wollen konsequent dass das ist
das entscheidende ich glaube es geht um
transparenz
die absender schafft muss einfach total
deutlich sein dass beispielsweise die
afg macht es ja zu sagen wir tun so als
würden wir nachrichten machen
das liegt überhaupt nicht in meinem oder
in unserem interesse menschen ihren
relativ im hinterland zu finden indem
man so tut als würden wir nachrichten
machen manchmal haben sie denn den
begriff newsroom verwenden dann tun sie
das mit der bewussten absicht grenzen zu
verwischen alter dem newsroom weil im
willy brandt haus gibt es seit 2010 auch
diesen begriff gibt es seit 2010
und gerade jetzt in der aktuellen
debatte also die sache ist ja die ich
glaube wir sind ja alle für die liberale
demokratie und das vertrauen in presse
und das vertrauen in politik ist
gleichermaßen wichtig damit das
funktioniert das heißt wenn wir in
meiner partei newsroom haben und durch
diese begrifflichkeit besteht auch nur
ein hauch der gefahr dass menschen das
falsch verstehen dann okay dann müssen
wir es wegen mir auch nicht so gehalten
dass der helm hat das programm kam bauer
nicht recht dass wir eigentlich neue
regeln brauchen
die debatten anders geführt werden die
frage werden anders geführt das ist
richtig und ohne twitter wird nicht
präsident geworden weil er sozusagen
sich sonst der kritik von indianischen
washington post und so weiter vielmehr
hätte aussetzen müssen über twitter
hatte ist alles übersprungen das wird
sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
rückgängig machen lassen
aber ich bin schon da vielleicht auch
ein bisschen vom alten schrot und korn
also ich hätte partei pressebericht ich
geglaubt und ich habe auch nicht auf die
idee gekommen dass auf einmal
parteipräsidenten achten dass das
parteipräsidium nicht der anspruch sein
partei heißt es ein teil ist parteiisch
und man möchte ja irgendwo und das ist
eben die funktion der journalisten
jemanden haben der information gewichtet
wertet einordnet sortiert natürlich mit
sorgfalt und so weil man das in der flut
der informationen selber gar nicht kann
jetzt kommt und jetzt kommt erst die
frage neben den klassischen medien die
diese aufgabe haben und wo ich mal sagen
bei den printmedien sehe ich noch nicht
das zukunftssichere geschäftsmodell
kommen jetzt andere dazu und das ist
jetzt für mich die spannende frage
finden wir durch youtuber oder andere
marken den ich dann auch so vertraue und
zwar quer durch die generationen als ich
muss zugeben ich gehört zu denen die
youtube weit unterschätzt haben
obwohl liegt bei etwas nachdenken es
hätte merken können warum youtube seine
glaubwürdigkeit hat wenn mein sohn ein
problem nicht lösen kann google teer und
dann wird er auf ein youtube video
verlinkt und auf einmal kann er
sozusagen sein iphone geht dann wieder
das für einen vertrauensgewinn für die
plattform bedeutet kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen ich habe ein problem
und dann juden verstanden dass ich es da
nicht eine lösung genau
und da das für die politik irgendwie
nutzbar zu machen wer vielleicht mal
darüber nach zu der blase brauchen wir
der journalismus nach erreicht dass wenn
es form gibt wo sie arbeiten wo es
podcast gibt ohne ende brauchen wir den
klassischen journalismus machen
natürlich auf jeden fall also ich glaube
auch wieso würde sich selber nicht als
journalist bezeichnen
geld macht er sonst eigentlich musik und
auf dem kanal auf dem das video
erschienen ist macht ja eigentlich sonst
video sieht man das letzte video was
jetzt danach online game ist eine schock
gold challenge mit julia wittig
also ganz typisches youtube video wie
man das auf zwei kanälen auch sie
deswegen also ich habe nicht das gefühl
dass er denkt dass das was er da gemacht
hat in irgendeiner form journalismus
ersetzen sollte da ist muss es
unglaublich wichtig sind ganz
essenzieller teil einer funktionierenden
demokratie und es wird immer
journalismus geben aber sehen sind liebe
liebe die grenzen jetzt so verwischt
werden das ist doch so also wenn ich
jetzt ich hab' podcast ganz verschiedene
ich habe die von von öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk ich habe die von
ihnen von also jede menge da weiß ich
doch als als hörer gar nicht mehr
ist das jetzt ja ein klassisch
journalistisches produkt ist es einfach
jemand der seinen meinung nach jetzt hat
man noch mal die frage brauchen wir
andere regeln ich glaube nicht ich
glaube dass youtube zb jetzt inzwischen
schon macht ist klar zu kennzeichnen wo
produkte her kommt man zum beispiel
steht jetzt unter einem video wird
wahrscheinlich bei diesem video das auf
youtube gibt auch dass sie entweder und
das ist ein angebot des öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunks
wenn das von russia today gepostet wurde
steht etwas anderes
und wer soll denn die regeln machen
also ich weiß ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine keiner einfach so auf wenige
machen soll ich bin aber der meinung
dass wir nicht mehrere regeln brauchen
sondern mehr medienkompetenz also ich
glaube das verständnis dafür was eine
gute quelle ist was ein seriöser beitrag
ist viel wichtiger als zu sagen wir
müssen den mund verbieten oder dafür
sorgen dass nur noch spezifische leute
auf youtube irgendwas machen dürfen was
er sich dafür ideen im raum stehen aber
ich glaube das internet und ist ja die
demokratisierung dieser meinung also die
möglichkeit dass jemand wie wieso
plötzlich die möglichkeit hat zwölf
millionen leute damit zu erreichen wir
den regen und die hat jeder der hat das
jetzt aus sehr vielen durchbrüchen
geschafft aber ja und welche gefahr
besteht denn dann da drin herdecker wenn
jeder eigentlich das so kann wo sehen
sie die gefahr weil wir sind zum
beispiel bei der wahl die fdp sehr aktiv
ist
die meisten follower von allen parteien
bei facebook zum beispiel also viele die
sich darauf beziehen also ist das dann
eine gefahr dass eben da der populismus
wächst ja wir sehen hier die gefahr
heute schon wir sehen sie in den
sozialen netzwerken
bz die man eigentlich besser digitale
netzwerke nennen sollte weil das soziale
da manchmal hinten runterfällt
wir sehen daß aufmerksamkeit
das kriegt um diejenigen bekommen die
zuspitzen die emotionalisieren die
polemisieren und wir sehen auch heute im
netz bei journalistischen angeboten das
häufig eben nicht dass sachliche stück
über den länderfinanzausgleich und
dessen oder vorn geklickt wird sondern
es wird daneben geklickt ein text wo in
der überschrift ziegenpeter vorkommt um
es mal sehr drastisch zu sagen also die
die vokabel die die jan böhmermann mit
blick auf herrn erdogan verwandt hat und
und wenn das sozusagen der wenn das der
trend ist dann macht es schon alles muss
journalismus der auch den namen noch
verdient ja bringt das in gefahr macht
es teilweise sogar unmöglich wenn wir
jetzt im kontext ist wieso videos von
populismus reden dann will ich mir
ehrlich gesagt wünschen dass populismus
so funktioniert weil 13 seiten fakten
mitzuliefern naja wenn wir das
populismus ist damals hat es
funktioniert es hat alles funktioniert
glaube ich weil eben in der überschrift
das wort zerstörung vorgekommen also ich
würde das ist doch nichts neues
boulevard dessen zeilen zuspitzungen
besser funktionieren als
länderfinanzausgleich sein und das war
auch schon so als das internet gerade
erst internet vaters dass da jetzt so zu
treffen dass eine entwicklung die ganz
neues ist ja so war das mit dem
populismus gebracht würde würde ich doch
gerne für eine klarstellung versuchen zu
sorgen also der jan werner müller das
ist der für populismus forscher sagt
populismus ist anti pluralistisch das
ist nicht derbe sprache oder irgendwie
sowas sondern es hat ein ganz klar
demokratiefeindlichen hintergrund
deshalb sprechen wir auch von
rechtspopulisten
re so ist kein populist in dem sinne
dass das muss man ganz klar festhalten
er ist polemisch und alles was dann
attributen man noch vielleicht sagen
kann ja aber er ist kein populist sodann
da würde ich ihnen widersprechen ich
hätte mir verkniffen aber weiß jetzt
noch mal hoch kam dieser schritt war ja
so eine diskussion geht auch immer
irgendwie weiter
ich wollte noch an ich wollte eigentlich
in anderen punkt ansprechen wir haben
unabweisbar einen gigantisch wachsende
zahl an quellen aus denen die uns
informieren können unser weltbild bleibt
aber nicht selbst erfahren sondern durch
quellen vermittelt insofern stellt sich
zwangsläufig die frage welchen quellen
glauben wir und da bin ich ganz bei
ihnen
es geht um medienkompetenz das kann
nicht der staat vorsortieren und dann
komme man sich angucken und überlegen
wie vermitteln die es hat ja einen grund
warum die afg von lügen presse weil sie
eben genau den seriösen quellen die
glaubwürdigkeit absprechen will damit
man ihren kanälen glaubt so kann sie ja
die frage ist nur wer sortiert ist keine
blasen muss hier müssen sie sagen also
wieder weg wie schafft man den
medienkompetenz wie kriegt man das hin
also aktuell sortieren dass algorithmen
die oft sehr intransparent sind finde
ich auch problematisch aber am ende des
tages sollte eigentlich jeder bürger in
der lage sein für sich selber zu
sortieren und diese kompetenz ist leider
nicht bei jedem vorhanden ich weiß nicht
ob die jemals bei jedem vorhanden sein
wird
aber da ist der punkt wo ich auf jeden
fall anfassen würde und ich finde wenn
jemand gezeigt hat wie man es richtig
macht dann wieso er hat sicherlich auch
fehler gemacht in seinem video
aber er hat zitiert er hat die quellen
angehängt er hat sich informiert und
klar passieren auch fehler und manche
sachen sind vielleicht auch ein bisschen
überspitzt oder sind weggelassen worden
ist in 55 minuten auch schwierig alles
irgendwie zu behandeln aber klar dass
vielleicht hätte ja auch mit einem
journalisten vorher zusammenarbeiten
können um noch irgendwie das ganze ein
bisschen runder machen zu können wir
weiß aber am ende des tages finde ich
hat er das gemacht was ich mir
eigentlich von allen youtube-videos
wünschen würde und wie gesagt es gibt
sie aber trotzdem sich entschieden nicht
bei diesem gemeinsam aufrufen mit zu
maklern denen es ja dann gab von 70 als
youtube warum haben sie dann nicht
mitgemacht weil ich persönlich kurz vor
der wahl oder auch generell ist
problematisch fand dazu aufzurufen eine
partei nicht zu wählen
einfach weil ich der meinung bin dass
eben genau das geld und sollte dass
leute anhand von informationen die man
ihnen präsentiert selber zu ihren den
schlüssen kommen ich finde sein video
hätte genauso gut funktioniert wenn er
nicht gesagt hätte wählt nicht diese
drei parteien und hätte dann vielleicht
aber nicht so große wellen geschlagen
also vielleicht war es richtig dass das
gemacht hat nur ich persönlich hab
gesagt dass ich stehe mehr für
politische bildung und deswegen möchte
ich lieber leute informieren und wenn
die faktenlage dann dafür sorgt dass
leute sagen dann wenig diese drei
parteien nicht dann sind das im
schlüssel die die bürger selber
getroffen haben
was muss man denn jetzt machen wir damit
dann der eine oder andere youtuber dann
doch denkt okay jetzt will ich mal
wieder spd was nehmen sie sich davor
so geht das überhaupt noch oder ist es
jetzt so kaputt gemacht dass immerhin
starte ich glaube also innerhalb von
drei tagen da jetzt formvollendet auf
allen ebenen muss ja nicht vergeben
zum einen dieses dieses auf augenhöhe
mal zu reagieren und das ernstnehmen und
es annehmen und das tatsächlich auch in
die reale politik mitzunehmen das ist ja
der erste schritt und gerade jetzt auch
an dieser stelle glaube ich der erste
wichtige schritt und das hat das ging
mir ja deutlich gemacht dass das jetzt
gerade passiert
und diese zweite frage also wie schaffen
wir es denn jetzt diese hier um leute in
diesem internet zu erreichen das ist ja
genau das was ich sage ich würde mir
wünschen dass das viel mehr an
persönlichkeiten hängt die erzählen was
sie tun warum sie es tun warum sie
politik machen was es bedeutet aber sehr
schwierig bei der spd streitet sich
jetzt gerade optimal ist jetzt noch
fraktionsvorsitzender bleibt und
erwähnte parteivorsitzende über frau
gramkow mauer gibt auch viel kritik
inzwischen an ihre person also wenn sie
sagen es liegt jetzt an persönlichkeiten
sind wir ja wieder weg von den inhalten
wohl doch alle sagen es geht doch
eigentlich um die inhalte dann so sind
sie doch im dilemma naja ich glaube aber
tatsächlich das eine funktioniert nicht
so gut
ohne das andere ich glaube und das also
wieso hat sich dahin gestellt und hat
das erklärt und er hat das seiner
community erklärt und das wäre das ist
tausendmal besser als hätten wir ein
explorer video gemacht ohne ohne
persönlichkeit also na klar brauchen wir
gute inhalte aber wir brauchen glaube
ich auch politikerinnen die gute rinn
sind sie zu erklären und ich weiß nicht
ob jetzt in jedem jede politikerin
youtube-kanal braucht es geht das
internet ist ja groß es gibt ja sehr
viele möglichkeiten mit menschen zu
sprechen auf verschiedenen kanälen
und was tun sie denn sagen was denken
und sagen youtuber sind kein moment
keine anderen menschen als nichtjurist
hingegen so berechneten jahre jünger und
da gibt es natürlich dann auch gruppen
und es gibt immer schwierigkeiten im
dialog zwischen generationen und
zwischen unterschiedlichen sozialen
schichten und so aber erstmal sollte man
sich vielleicht ein bisschen davon frei
machen dass man die so eine medien
tasche steckt also das sind einfach dass
man menschen die haben ihre ihre wünsche
die haben ihre vorstellung und sein
irgendwie spaß sich jetzt irgendwie
auszudrücken und genauso wie man mit
anderen menschen darüber sprechen muss
als politiker wie stellt ihr euch euer
leben vor
und was können wir als politiker dafür
tun dass es dann auch so leben können
genauso würde ich auch mit den menschen
sprechen ganz einfach aber die frage ist
wie wichtig also weil man jetzt ja mag
das geht viel wieder auch ins personal
herdecker wie würden sie es beurteilen
da ist es ist diese botschaft angekommen
im politischen berlin oder ist das im
moment einfach nur hysterisch ein
bisschen aufgeladen nach dem schlechten
wahlergebnis und dann geht man wieder
zur tagesordnung
ja ich glaube da kommen zwei sachen
zusammen noch einmal sind die beide
volksparteien tief verunsichert das ist
das eine
weil sie die spd stärker die union
sprecher beide mehr und mehr doch in in
die krise geraten und auch in eine
identitätskrise geraten und dann gibt es
eine zweite quelle der verunsicherung
und das sind eben immer noch die ist
eben immer noch die digitalisierung
selber die revolution von der ich eben
gesprochen habe die ist im gange dass
ein youtuber den gestern niemand kannte
heute sozusagen die die debatte in
deutschland bestimmt das ist einfach
eine sache die sich auch hier am tisch
glaube ich vor zwei wochen noch niemand
so hat vorstellen können
der unterschied ist dass wir darauf
nicht
reagieren mussten die wer darauf
reagieren musste war in erster linie cdu
die ist an dieser herausforderung
gescheitert
mein punkt ist wenn ich das dann zum
schluss noch sagen darf also ich hoffe
halt darauf dass im netz insbesondere
wenn es um journalismus geht der den
namen auch verdient ja dass da noch
sachliche inhalte auch eine chance haben
und nicht nur inhalte die in irgendeiner
form emotionalisieren weil ich auch
glaube dass das nicht nur den
journalismus in gefahr bringen sondern
auch die politik na ja das wird
natürlich auch voraussetzen dass die
bemühungen die es ja bei den klassischen
medien gibt auch im internet stärker fuß
zu fassen dass die auch dann diese form
mit weiterentwickeln
die im internet anderswo schon gang und
gäbe ist
ja es gibt doch was hat sich insofern
werden die dinge zusammenfließen ich
wäre jetzt auch nicht ja nicht
pessimistisch ich vertraue auf eine
freiheitliche offene pluralistische
gesellschaft auch im netz und auch in
den dialogen den wir da braucht ja sehr
hoher ingrid arthur burg angesprochen
und kevin kühnert hat auch aufregung
gesorgt mit äußerungen ist es dann jetzt
eben wieso der blase ist das nicht
letztendlich dann doch ein generationen
dingen wo man sagt okay die jugendlichen
sind hat die jüngeren leute die sagen
halt eben dinge die dürfen ein bisschen
wilder sein und dann beruhigen die sich
schon wieder
nein ich glaube also ich glaube beim
schüler wandel oder ich bin doch das
wort klimawandel schwierig bei dieser
klimakatastrophe volle regale stehen da
haben junge menschen einfach so wie alle
anderen auch aber junge menschen am
meisten
ein riesiges problem und es geht hier
nicht um youtube schlosses kroko wie es
im titel steht sondern es geht um junge
menschen für eine zukunft und zwar für
eine zukunft also dass es überhaupt eine
zukunft gibt und da finde ich
ist jede partei eingeladen gerne sich
daran zu beteiligen und das muster nicht
auf youtube passieren und da ist mir
auch völlig egal ob das charismatische
leute sind oder sich langweilte leute
ich möchte einfach nur dass wir politik
haben die dafür sorgt dass meine tochter
irgendwann noch mal leben hat vielen
dank ich glaube da haben wir einigkeit
hier am tisch und das spornt uns auch an
ich glaube auch hier in der phoenix
runde noch mehr inhaltliche debatten zu
führen also ganz herzlichen dank dafür
und heute abend geht es natürlich wie
immer weiter mit phoenix der tag in bonn
dort ist mein kollege thomas gerade der
garde der bringt sie auf den neuesten
stand der dinge und ich wünsche ihnen
schöne feiertag und wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]